silver unitards that can't be all you
have to give Barack Obama credit he has
overcome a great deal not just he is an
african-american Barack Hussein Obama is
his name his middle name is the last
name of Iraq's former tyrant his last
name rhymes with Osama that's not easy
to overcome I think we all remember the
ill-fated 1944 presidential campaign of
gay Dolf Hitler
yeah
it's such a shame tiller had so many
good ideas I just couldn't get past the
name and the mustache but are you ready
to have a wonderful show ladies and
gentlemen and welcome back to this town
I'm delighted that you're here we're
going to have a great night and it's
time for our first presenter by the way
this is probably a good time to mention
this is the environmentally conscious
Green Oscars so tonight all of our
presenters will be walking all the way
to the microphones please welcome
Jennifer Garner
a great costume designer has to be an
expert in history world cultures fashion
color fabric display a flair for math
and physics and be a good communicator
and one more thing you need to be really
quick with a pair of scissors if you
have all those skills you can rise to
the top of your profession just like
this year's nominees for achievement in
costume design across the universe
costume designed by Albert Walski
atonement costume designed by Jacqueline
Duran Elizabeth the Golden Age costume
designed by Alexandre Bern
Le'Veon Rose costume designed by Merritt
Allen Sweeney Todd the Demon Barber of
Fleet Street costume designed by Colleen
Atwood and the first Oscar of the
evening goes to Alexandra burn for
Elizabeth the Golden Age
this is the first Academy Award and
fourth nomination for Alexander Berg she
was previously nominated in this
category for Hamlet
Wow um thank you to the Academy thank
you to working title and universal to
shaker and to Kate and a huge thank you
to my brilliant team and to my family
thank you
though winner it's a tie a tie Catherine
half there were five great performances
I mean I thought mine was pretty good
great I'm excited
good yeah pretty good
but you know I thought why don't they
give us all Platts you're done with it
you know
hello gorgeous
hello gorgeous thanks great
with Steve Carell and Hathaway and
George Clooney here on ABC